en un año normal Este campo de maíz ya
habría sido cosechado
nacional
ya está seco tenemos que traerlo 5000
toneladas de maíz hay que transportarlas
a algún sitio inmediatamente a los que
necesitan No necesitamos tanto pero por
ahora esta agricultor y voluntario de la
defensa territorial no tiene más remedio
que dejar el maíz en el campo o de esa
lleva ya dos semanas paralizada Desde
hace dos semanas no hay prácticamente
ninguna posibilidad de vender grano a
través de los puertos de la región de
Odessa
aparte de los puertos del mar Negro No
hay forma realista de exportar las
cantidades necesarias
el corredor de cereales era un
salvavidas absoluto para nosotros sin él
no habríamos podido vender nuestros
productos así conseguimos vender la
mitad de nuestro trigo y la mitad de
nuestra cebada a través de ese corredor
de cereales
lo que queda está en estos graneros
qué podemos hacer solo almacenar
el viernes en uno de los puertos de la
región de Odessa el icaria Angel estaba
siendo cargado con 30.000 toneladas de
trigo con destino a Etiopía
Ucrania rechaza las acusaciones rusas de
que el acuerdo no ha ayudado al
continente africano todo
se han enviado 51 buques a países
africanos con 1,2 millones de toneladas
de carga teniendo en cuenta que en total
al navegador unos 400 barcos gracias a
este corredor eso significa que más del
10% fue a África
sin embargo ahora no está nada Claro si
este barco usar para el domingo como
estaba previsto